there's financial carnage everywhere
asset prices are falling off a cliff and
a lot of people are asking what's the
fastest way you could go broke all of
the investing titans they all agree
there is one way that is the fastest way
to go broke and that is leverage don't
take my word for it though let me tell
you what they've said first up we've got
charlie munger he says smart men go
broke three ways liquor ladies and
leverage then his partner warren buffett
following it and saying now the truth is
the first two he just added because they
started with l it's leverage then we can
go and we can take a look at seth
clarkman almost every financial blow up
is because of leverage
next up howard marks in addition to
magnifying losses as well as gains
leverage carries an extra risk on the
downside that isn't offset by
accompanying upside the risk of ruin and
then last but not least ray dalio coming
in and saying using leverage is like
playing russian roulette it means that
you are inevitably going to get a bullet
in the head now of course using leverage
ends up being a really enticing
proposition hey you can make way more
money when things go up but just like
there's upside advantage there is a
massive downside disadvantage and so
making sure that you don't use leverage
especially if you don't know what you're
doing is an important component of
learning about finance and investing
when the titans speak when the legends
of the last few decades all agree you
should pay attention the timeless
investing principle of avoiding leverage
to avoid ruin is an important one that
many people are learning all over again
in the recent price sell-off